my name is Tim che I'm the acquiring
editor for
world language textbooks that you
versity press and first of all I'd like
to thank you all for coming spend a
great event so far before I talk about
what we're trying to do to update the
materials keep French and actually going
there just some people who asked that I
extend their good wishes to Pierre and
extend their disappointment that they
couldn't be here for various reasons
several members of the staff had WGBH
and Annenberg media couldn't make it and
wanted to extend their good wishes to
Pierre
Maria Kaczynski who actually will be
here tonight at the banquet it was
extremely upset that she couldn't be
heard for today's festivities and wanted
me to let everyone know that mary
coleman who in the 90s worked for about
ten years promoting frenchman action and
probably worked with many of you also
had another engagement and i have a
letter of two Pierre from the chairman
of the board of Chicago Bears Michel
mckowski and it says this I guess shows
you the reach of French in action
dear Pierre congratulations to you and
the entire crew who created French in
action twenty-five years ago what you
accomplished is nothing short of
astonishing so many students and adult
learners have learned to speak French
with facility thanks to your pioneering
efforts in the 1960s before there was fr
a I struggled through many hours in the
language lab at Yale the materials then
were boring sleep-inducing and not
interactive years later still wanting to
improve my French I was thrilled to
discover FIA and this weekend he's
actually in Paris as he says using the
skills he he gained from French and
action so he's very sorry couldn't be
here but very happy for Pierre so what I
wanted to talk to you about was the
textbooks workbooks an audio program of
French and action which is what Yale
University Press has been fortunate
enough to publish for the past 23 years
and French an accident I don't know if
it's still unique in this regard but
it's certainly unique amongst all the
products I've dealt with is that as I
heard Pierre say before with French in
action the French in action video is the
course the textbook is just
lament eree so me as if we're not the
publisher of the video so as the
publisher of the textbook workbook an
audio program our challenge is what can
we do to improve the materials that
exist to support the French and action
video and help professors like yourself
keep using French in action because if I
could if I had to one sentence say what
I've heard from many many French
professors out there who are familiar
enough with French and action to know
how effective it is is they say things
like French and action is the best
method there is but I can't use it for
various reasons that might be that
copyright on a textbook is 1994 there
are more members of their staff that
aren't familiar with it and they get
voted down and it gets pushed out of
their curriculum and you know as with
any program that's been around for a
long time
French in action uses dwindling and so
my goal is to increase its use and this
is sure I'm sure this is something that
the Yale University Press should have
done a long time ago and they're
probably a number of reasons why the
main one probably is that because the
video is so comprehensive and so much
the focal point of the course there
hasn't been the ability and there isn't
today the ability to to update the video
or to newa new vid do a new video if
that would even be desirable so but what
I do want to do is do whatever we can to
improve the materials around the video
with input from all of you and keep
wrenching actually going as long as we
can for all the teachers who who know
how effective it is so in March of this
year I did an online survey of this went
out only to French and action users will
call them meeting professors either who
use it now and high school teachers and
middle school teachers or those who have
used it in the past but people who are
in our database this users and I was
looking for information about there
use their thoughts on using it today in
their classrooms and so I got a lot of
tremendous feedback a lot of it from
some people in this room and I just want
to read you a couple of the comments
which I think were typical some of them
you may not agree with but of course
that's fine one person said the reason
for dropping French in action from their
curriculum we wanted something that had
Internet online support as well as the
book workbook and videos and the
workbook and videos are not as
up-to-date as they might be another
person said we learned to deal with the
obviously out of date elements currency
and prices telephones etc the somewhat
old-fashioned style of some of the
dialogue and such things as tobacco and
alcohol that probably wouldn't appear in
a more modern textbook someone else said
we use French and action for 20 years I
learned French with it I loved it sadly
two new teachers dropped it probably
because it was old that was a terrible
mistake
what they are using now insert the name
of another textbook is junk if it is not
updated soon we will stop using it after
22 years followed by three exclamation
points so some of the I also ask people
what is it that we could update that
would make it more likely for you to
either keep using it or perhaps go back
to it if your school has been forced to
drop it
some people said I used to mention
accidents for nearly 10 years I dropped
it because it was too franco centric and
this is just as important it wasn't up
to date with online material someone
else said similar comment you need way
more about the rest of the francophone
world French and action is notoriously
Franco centric and that's a problem
someone said multiculturalism is a high
priority and by the way I'm going to
open up to the floor in a few minutes
after I finish talking because I want to
hear from all of you what your thoughts
are and what
we can do to help improve the the
existing materials so kind of the
consensus so I haven't talked yet about
what we're trying to do we're we're
updating the textbook and the workbook
with with new editions of them so far
what we've got going into them are
references which will make current
things like currency telecommunication
the Internet
eliminating out-of-date occupations and
adding newer occupations more
multiculturalism so more about the
francophone world that's obviously a
touchy subject so that's something that
we're going to be discussing before we
you know before Pierre decides what
we're going to do with that changes to
the city of Paris in the 21st century
adding more online materials another
touchy subject which I guess kind of
goes against the grain of French and
action is more written grammar exercises
which was I'm not saying we're doing
that that was something that's requested
so where can we do these things I think
probably the in the in terms of the
books the easiest place to update is the
document section because they're not so
strictly tied to the lessons in the
video we can also add new exercises to
the workbook and we can add more online
material and as far as you know adding
any online material or electronic
resources I want to assure you given the
technical difficulties we had this
morning that I'm the acquiring editor
and I'm not the multimedia producer so
you don't have to worry about that
so Owen other-- thing which was Pierre's
idea which he's working on and this is
something that he plans on including in
both the new textbook and French and
interaction is something he's calling
them a real or diary which he could tell
you about for a minute what it would
entail well it will we have discovered
and then he knows a diary
which he has been writing since she was
10 until now so we were going through it
we find some little topics which have
things to do with what we're talking in
a given lesson but which was written at
a much later date so that we we coat
that we got permission from her at all
to quote some passages from her diary
and we'll select some of those passages
and reproduce them thank you so I'd like
to open it up to the floor now one of
the things that I'd like to you to
address if anyone has any thoughts on it
is I'm curious if any of your schools
that you teach at are using a main let's
say you're using French in action or
you're not using French in action but if
any of the other languages if you're
using a main level text for beginning
course that is strictly electronic that
has no paper workbook textbook anything
if it's just an online or an electronic
program they should to know if anyone
has that another thing which I want to
discuss with you either one-on-one or
you can bring it up now or email me it
doesn't matter is we're going to be
looking for some assistance I've already
talked a few people about this if anyone
wants to help contribute to the content
of the new textbook and workbook
cultural information different things
that might go into the documents or
ancillary materials for online some of
you have built up you know virtual
practically libraries of supplementary
materials that you've been using for
many years with French in action if
anybody wants to talk to me about you
know possibly working with that that
would be great but I'm interested to
know as I said about the electronic
question of any fully electronic
textbooks and just what it is that you
would like to see happen with the
materials that are French in action
other than the video and brian has the
mic
if anyone wants to contribute anything
so any comments about the future of the
the non video materials first we'll have
a general discussion about the future of
French and action in general that in
terms of Tim's points for the for the
text materials in particular hi I
haven't haven't thought this through
very much but I've but we're talking a
lot about how we teach I've been using
French and action for 23 years and in a
high school level and I wonder if we
loved it when the 1994 version broke it
down into two you know lo que Abruzzo
Calle who I'm wondering if there's a way
to break it down even further into into
three books because I think the document
are so wonderful that and and it's
always a question of time and you know
is there a way to use at our level is
would there be a way to use French in
action a little differently and not be
not ask kids to buy a book that they're
only going to use half of for example I
don't know if you've thought about that
breaking it down or into four books or
something like that so that we can use
you know we never got to lesson 52 but
we certainly in two years we got to the
late 40s and now we aim for lesson 25 I
love the idea that there's going to be
updating of the duck you mom because I
think they're really rich and there's
lots of potential and opportunity with
those with with everything but that
that's an easy way to supplement I mean
Hobart could have visited places in the
francophone world with his wealthy
family and me I could dream about things
and it's exciting to hear but there's
all not of the matter you don't - so
there are all kinds of ways to be
creative I think but possibly not
limiting us two to two books right I
think that's a great point my
understanding has always been that
generally speaking when colleges use
French in action it's a two-year program
and high schools go at about half the
pace making it a four-year program which
is what you're referring to
I think it's definitely it is that not
the case okay
so you did it in two years but do you
have a semester system so that he'd want
for books for okay okay I mean breaking
it down is definitely a viable option
and I think it would before we did it we
would just want to get more feedback I
would do another survey of for example
all the high school teachers I'm not
sure if any college teachers want to
come in on that if there'd be any
colleges that you think would want it
broken down more than in part one in
part two I said you to know that two
other comments about the non video
materials a little feedback here because
we want to talk about you know the
future of French and action in general
you know how to continue this this is
the 25th anniversary how do we continue
it on into the 21st century so your your
your input is what's going to be
necessary for the you know to continue
the success of this program since I mean
you have made it a success
since language is living and evolving I
think it would be helpful if there could
be some way to isolate expressions that
are somewhat outdated and maybe offer
more not necessarily unacceptable as
modern expressions often are but just
sort of an update so that to answer
those people who think that French and
action is outdated are you referring to
the expressions obviously in the video
so you're saying maybe in the workbook
or the textbook where they're not
identified currently identify them and
use it as something that can be taught
about explaining them more because
they're harder to understand now so what
no just because there's somewhat
outdated they're not used anymore
okay I mean like miss Daley Buddha
gummies nobody uses that anymore I'm
sure there are other examples I've
taught with French assistants who say Oh
we'd never say that now I think by and
large yes indeed French and actions
great success is that it is very
authentic but it's those little places
that aren't so modern that if it those
of us who don't get to go to France all
the time if we knew that reliably there
are some expressions that really
wouldn't be used if we could know what
they are and what would be used in place
of those well you might might be good if
you could make a list of those
expressions which you find a little bit
too old you know I was suggested here we
could replace a zoot by Putin to mail
them back I I don't think you should
replace anything in French interaction
because you know if if you start
replacing mr. repoed ego may suit with
the you know vulgar PETA emailed it's
just going to become you know more like
the United States which is the most
degenerate culture in the world and it's
system to generate because you know for
me I just learned French just as a lark
by watching French in action you know
it's it's an idealized world and I just
think there should be some standards you
know and French and action sets a
standard their eyes you know culture you
know stands above but I forgot I was
going to say but uh let me ask one more
thing and that is how do you think that
the Internet has changed language
learning because like I said when I when
I learned French it was with French and
action in the early 90s and the only
access I had was with French video tapes
and French and action but now I have
streaming audio on the Internet and
that's really changed the way that for
me in my opinion you can have a whole
immersion just by listening to internet
streaming audio and it's free and thank
you thank you that's all I have to say
we Austin soon come on July mr. Schue
language geek who fed the homeless see
this expression presume on the tip of
Doherty server error mode etc the pollen
seeker said long lousy external evil
achieve is to convert evil show de
formación special the shadow to compound
the secure zone 0 toda Don Emilio a tree
do Lisa et cetera
see pal along the gripping of gazebo
alabanza dubbed he preapred 2002 she
recovers recover some Phoenix patience a
problem on Kelly diva
oh poor elderly strong really don't see
a year a small a centralized office
complexes with marquel cashews EP
episode Calcasieu source and Khazraj a
complete no anger la nouvelle génération
key fell along etc dunk from modulation
wanna see Chucky
kappa to meto do i effect is not set to
standard because a calico shoes do
remodeler linguistique skin Amish man
Antonio diversion to me he also saw
Japan a Christian Co cool along the
French in action swear that he hoped
additions con-caevo mr. roberto gomes in
expression for not on patrol in all of
you may take away my next question yes
at last all along Ikki bomb soprano
success aloysius doran long Seleucid
evolved ADA - very Cal Cal Poly's
maternal sector could be a suit Leon
senior French elections over Cornell's
super Alice report wrote me potato
osseous is expressive hola como comes
the festival cereal Alicia's were along
the neck reference the vada is
especially use and Hatice material the
dickly hello effective Mahaprabhu
suicune a sort of not sickly
yeah I was gonna say I know we're not
supposed to talk about the video but
talking about French interaction they
were adding more modern videos right for
the examples of like Bonjour and they
show more modern videos and if they're
gonna do that for French interaction you
know why not put those on the original
videos you know just those original
videos without changing the storyline
I think the storyline pretty much should
stay the same it's pretty much like you
said an idealized world in Paris
focusing on Paris and then as far as the
text goes but as far as the workbook
goes for Yale Press if I were to see
something different from the last
edition what would be an improvement
would be maybe more more cartoons and
pictures make it more a little a little
more livelier
and then you know when I actually learn
French from French and action so I was
always jumping from the workbook to the
study guide you know it would be nice to
take both and maybe blend them together
you know have the information there
right you know because I was going back
to from one chapter to another in there
and lastly it would be great just with
technology now with the audio and the
exercises there's so many things online
now where you have you know you you you
listen to the audio and and if there's a
way with you know if you buy the
workbook then you can have access to
like an online version that gives you
the answers maybe so you don't have to
go to the back of the workbook to get
the answers and maybe blends the audio
online you know so you're not having to
put in a CD or no I'm saying like a key
a workbook have you ever kiyah heard of
them mmhmm yeah
yeah I just wanted to clarify I would
never ever want to touch French and
actions original recording its psyche
wholesome I just thought given the
comments that I've had from assistants
I just don't that I've worked with maybe
there could be a forum or something
something sort of live where you could
type in an expression and ask if there
is a maybe a more modern equivalent or
something but I'm a total agreement with
you I love the traditional roots of
French and action I wouldn't change that
but it'd be nice to have some way to
access what might be a little more
modern maybe through a forum okay just
picking up there's now been a couple of
suggestions of having some type of
online exercise compendium the Kea was
mentioned speaking as someone who does
use in a more advanced course a grammar
book with a Kea adjunct and who's seen
her son go through a high school program
with a Kea adjunct you know what the
only thing that makes Kea any better
than an old-fashioned and I mean grammar
translation method is the fact that it's
electronic and you know what after about
five minutes our students wise up to
that I think maybe some type of I like
the idea of a forum where teachers can
share their ideas but frankly when
someone says we need more an Salieri's
all I'm hearing really is you know what
I am so overworked I don't have time and
I think French and actually really does
have so much in it already if you have
17 students no you don't have to have 17
questions if your questions are well
enough devised the same question can be
answered differently by all 17 students
so I think there are other ways of
simplifying our task as faculty members
or as teachers rather than farming out
all the creativity and expecting someone
is going to do this all for us
uh mine just goes along with changing
the video I think that the video should
definitely stay the same and like
everyone agrees but more importantly
just because and just going along with
why we should also keep french and
action in the classroom you know we
wouldn't change a piece of literature
just because time has changed and we
wouldn't stop reading a piece of
literature just because we've moved on
in a different piece of time and I
really see French in action is you know
a piece of art also and a piece of
literature that these cans can learn
about you know what what life was like
then and and I think as a workbook
component we could always have like text
box in the workbook that give you know
expressions from today that or we could
ask them you know and in the forum I
think is also a great idea so just
things to add in the workbook you know
there could even just be like a text
block like AO Chaudhary s :
Cusco Angie and I think that that could
be a really great supplement to help
students compared to what it was and
what it is today
Oh some say she was easier to show JAV
dunno if you like I mean if you like to
change everything in the book you're
gonna have to ask yourself little girls
for 10 years old in fines now what would
it sound like at all
Japan example today in exist approach
Rianna Falls here Treasury - hi John T
Tebow Donna vocabulary in petite fille
Buddhism Magnon say ho ho ho say to open
arms Virginia says ma petite neoscope
Arkansas which provides actually
occurred on sank on so actually sad sack
was visible I assumed were excellent
leave a check for a [ __ ] emoticons
nila text to be ma'am measure pass to
sink a Sunday show Jake laughs assault
the communicate a portion ma'am could
they call Bhutan say no and from page
with a fraction actions to several of us
concept by exact amok Kamara fair a
large I regret the fat
important role in balancing on the
reservoir como a push hey como como
introduce it method Japan's kisses Pusan
forever please don't como esto hace Avex
admitted on typical man affair reversal
on Tonka format Levinson artwork is it
to Joe's present on the Commission
Oh Tim I think this is it sounds like a
great opportunity to use the the
web-based materials to open up all these
topics to talk about the francophone
world have some examples maybe some
expressions you could click on and see
some updated expressions and maybe
references to things like Belal and or
whatever and to Monsieur the Pope is so
not I don't want to give you more work
to do but I think this is a wonderful
opportunity today we have everybody here
maybe we can get Marian Robert to do
some sort of introductory you know 25
years later to introduce to the new
language what their children are telling
them what their francophone friends are
telling them just a few episode I mean
for you to go back to Paris and do 52
more episodes but maybe a few a few
episodes that can be on the website that
can be in the supplemental material to
introduce some of these changes and
updates thank you I am as far as making
changes to the video into the textbook
this is an argument that can go back and
forth constantly whenever you use
something that is considered either a
form of slang or just an expression or
you know just something that people say
that's not really standardized you will
always going to run into the problem of
it either becoming outdated or falling
into disuse or being interpreted
differently by different people
depending on their backgrounds so as far
as updating to newer expressions it's
really not going to solve the problem as
far as the online reference is for how
someone would say it nowadays yes you
can go online watch videos listen to the
radio but it's difficult really
sometimes to find an explanation of what
these newer expressions are which being
newer are not by default more vulgar but
ultimately it's a situation where so
long as we're using non standardized
French we're going to run into this
problem it's more I think isolating
those expressions and just simply
explaining what they mean maybe with a
side note simply saying that you may
hear this expression differently and
possibly giving you no reference to
online resources or other known
resources
they did hear an expression they would
be able to find the answer of what it
could possibly mean I think that would
probably be the easiest way rather than
going through the expense of trying to
change the video itself and trying to
change the textbooks itself it's just
one of those things where if it's just a
figure of speech then it can fall out of
fashion or it can change so updating it
to a new a figure of speech is not going
to fix that problem one area however in
which I think this our students want new
vocabulary is in the explosion of
Technology and especially communications
technology they're all interested in how
to say a computer an iPod a blog and and
if this could be somehow added none I
know that it can't be added easily to a
video but it could certainly be added
somewhere in the in the written
materials so that quickly we would be
able to start using that vocabulary
vocabulary in class without having them
totally lost
there will be something that she says
all right at in 19 1990 and another
thing 95 another thing five years later
you see so we can have a series of
different expressions there which will
be supposedly following the evolution
you have a great resource and all the
teachers who've been teaching with
French and action and former students
Tim and besides just putting out a
survey and getting some answers and
going back to the office you might put
your technology to work to make a blog
or a wiki and keep asking these
questions and posing them to the
community and get some answers and you
know keep this forum going not just for
today next six months and see what you
can come up with also so put the
technology to work to help prepare these
ideas and that's great sources not just
go back in to make another survey on
paper
she of course preparation for example
for all the chapters I'm sorry can
understand the question have you thought
of publishing someone's course
preparation like an instructor who
prepares its classes every week has a
theory of of course prepared so I've
just thought of publishing it for
example I'll because I'm following up on
the question as nowadays new instructors
don't know how to teach it so maybe
there is a little berry published the
instructors guide but will it be
possible to publish along the instructor
guide you know course preparation you
know exercise my existence why do you do
in class really the tradition but
someone you know ok
could be inspiring you could be some
master classes
some of us even having a resource of the
videos of these little reenactments that
students are doing in their classes it
was fun for us today just to see a
sampling and there could be a place on
the website where people are given
permission to have a sampling of their
little mini videos because it's very
inspiring
I would certainly after seeing the ones
today be inspired to go back to class
and say gosh let's let's see what else
we can make together you know it's just
makes them more excited about it so
there could be a resource of those
materials too instead of just hearing
about them in the act Phil newsletter or
something like that it's - buried they
keep this stuff active and animated and
accessible together
I would just like to second the idea
about giving more working more with the
teachers than with the material itself
that I really find excellent and as a
young teacher myself I had trouble
figure it out on my I mean I wasn't on
my own I was reading the guide and
thence and the study guide but I would
think if you really want to give French
Connection an extra push it would be
more focusing on the teacher as as the
the medium and not the medium itself not
technology but I think there is a way I
mean I'm speak for myself it took me
time to understand like how to make used
it to the fullest and cover make this
bridge between now and my students
difficulties and and what I would like
them to to use and when we work with the
teachers more I think this would solve
all the most of all the criticism you
might be hearing I don't think it's in
the method thank you
I'm not known for Nexus yeah but maybe
we can have a Facebook page for French
and action teachers we can all join and
we can you know okay for after today
is there anyone wants a volunteer to do
that or I could set it up can you set
that out okay and you have all our
emails right and you can email us and
then we can join on Facebook and we can
share our comments and ideas and post
videos post those videos on Facebook
other ideas or comments about not just
continuing you know the success of
French and action but taking it into the
into the 21st century proselytizing a
bit how do we convince other teachers to
do what we've been doing to just sort of
share that joy in teaching that you know
we found worked so well with our
students but just a little anecdote here
about my own particular great state of
New Jersey Bergen County not not a poor
County by any stretch of the imagination
just replace their middle school Spanish
teachers with rosetta stone and so you
know it's not just an academic exercise
that we're discussing here but it's
really about the vitality of language
teaching so your ideas for how to how to
not just maintain the current situation
but also to spread it and expand it
would be would be most welcome there was
an earlier comment about the about the
replacement of the video that you had
seen in the in the interactive version
what you saw there was technology which
states you know five or six years ago
and an interactive version of French and
action would would indicate the the
three things that you saw first it would
would have segmented playback something
where you could repeat over and over
again you saw when the word map C was
clicked on that there was the the potty
pedagogy K would no longer be different
from the video but something accessible
at any moment which is what we do on our
presentation of teaching and then we saw
a bit at the end of
an interactive speaking exercise where
we replaced
nihei in the dialog which could be done
for for any other character so if you
have ideas about how technology might be
used as well as I mentioned for our
panel I'm teaching almost every
individual in fact every individual up
there has been aggressively engaged and
how to bring the computer technology
into their teaching of French so if you
have ideas on that as well we'd love to
when John was up talking about the
French interaction he did say there was
going to be a iPad version right is that
right John
it will work on i-10 I think that's
something you know my school just bought
iPads for the eighth grade class and
there's nothing I was looking there's
really nothing in French right now
that's worth buying you know in French
interaction that would be fantastic to
see something like that on iPad well one
of the one of the big differences
between rosetta stone and French and
action as is or any future of French in
action is the lack of cultural
culturally authentic images it's the
same red balloon in French as it is in
Chinese as it is in Spanish so so in the
Indy 50 pedagogy which are taken
directly from a television and film it's
culturally authentic material and that
could only be swapped out if swapped out
with culturally authentic images and
videos as well and that's just terribly
important you know who tell you it's not
a good day it's not a good day they they
look different if you're if you're in
Italy if you're in France what part of
France are you an exception not that
this is what we should be teaching high
school students phone
any other comments questions concerns
yes Carol Heron speaking again there are
some changes though in the new materials
because you don't want to get people
excited about getting a new addition and
they say oh they just changed the cover
or something so and I know you're going
to make changes and I think the Macanudo
sounds like a wonderful idea
and I'm bringing more things on perhaps
on a website that was active redoing the
tests I was going to ask you was there
any thought about doing redoing the test
banks have you been thinking about that
is that not in your plan I was actually
thinking about that now it's going to
ask you I was wondering how many people
use the test Bank or if them don't even
know it exists how many would think they
would really benefit from it because we
can send it to you but yeah we can
definitely we should and well redo the
test Bank I know at our school we used
for introduction until four or five
years ago I used it when I was in high
school and we loved the test Bank we
tended to cut and paste different
exercises we haven't very very useful
but not necessarily you know all
together like the idea of it one thing
that when we use when we would use the
workbook sometimes we found that
exercises were simply too long we would
have signed an exercise students would
open the workbook up ah this is too long
and not even started I think one thing
that unfortunate students have adapted
to is a shorter attention span and it's
not and I agree with you about the about
the Kea it's not that you have to make
it shiny it's still the same thing still
have to do the work but but keeping them
a little bit more engaged by moving from
one I could activity to the next I think
would be might be a good adaptation for
a new addition Carol made a comment a
couple of minutes ago about you know
will there be what kind of changes will
there be and I talked a little bit about
them we're not the kind of publisher
like many
there we're not a major publisher like
many of the major publishers where you
know they're they're churning out new
editions of books every two or three
years and their sole reason in my
opinion is to fight the used book market
and so there's making very modest
changes it's kind of a big deal for us
to do a new edition especially of
something like French in action so we're
going to do it we're going to do a
significant significantly new edition
the issue of course is the tug of war
between the video which is the core of
the course on which is so sacred it's so
perfect as it is and how do we work
around it by just improving the parts
that that should be improved
first came out would be a : teachers
wait
I think when one thing you can add you
know you of course is the euro the
valley you know there's extra dish
things that have come along I think it
would be needing echoing with this
gentleman said over here was since we
have Robert me rain still you know and
seeing them today just was so exciting
you know if there was an extra chapter
maybe of them you know and if there if
there's one thing I can be a me be added
and they can kind of reminisce and you
can maybe use them to bring in the stuff
that's happened in the last twenty five
years some of the changes may be through
them even you know it was not I
understands not touching the video you
know it is a jewel and it's a work of
art that should be left alone but if you
add baby like on DVDs how you have that
extra video that you had you know extras
and have maybe them now today I think
that could be a big selling point to for
people because my students are always
asking what do they look like today you
know and that would be great on the new
edition have just one extra little
episode of them you know maybe we could
maybe mister compress can use his
imagination you know to come up with
some little story of what they've been
doing the last 25 years you know after
they were in the South of France you
know they got married had kids and what
happened you know did you say this
already is there a target date I didn't
say it already know we're expecting to
have the books ready for the fall of
2012 so they'll go into production next
spring or summer and then they'd be
ready the following spring of 2012 of
course used in fall 2012 I think we're
just about set I just want to make say
one more thing before I let you go we're
gonna have an hour and a half to relax
before the start of the cocktail hour at
6:30 at Commons if anybody doesn't know
how to get to Commons
you can see me or ash or Brian and we
can give you directions
but while the have you all here I just
wanted to say I'm just talking to you as
French scholars a teachers not as
necessary expansion action users but I'm
interested in acquiring language
textbooks in general so if you are
working on something if you see a gap
that's in the Year curricula where there
are any good books or instructional
materials meeting it and you want to see
something developed just come see me
tonight email me whatever and we'll just
talk about maybe what you're working on
or what one of your colleagues is
working on or anything like that so just
throwing that out there to you so it's
over for the day and we'll see you at
the cocktail hour thank you